so it seems like we may have something
in common where i started a company
uh that did not work out i feel like
like your company came a lot closer to
get to working out and that
certainly no one bought my little
company uh to employ us in the way that
google
on your company so can you tell us a
little bit more about your
entrepreneurial uh arc with
apture because as someone who started a
company myself it was very very hard
um it sounds like you had some ups and
downs too
yeah absolutely and it's funny i don't
talk about this that much um so app sure
just so i
explained what it was um uh the phrase
we came up with it's it's like lighter
fluid for sparks of curiosity
uh it was a a service that um
when a publisher like the economist or
new york times put it on their website
it would create this ability for a
reader to get on the fly multimedia
explanations about any topic
first started out as a publisher tool so
we had like the climate change blog on
the new york times and
um several other sites basically linking
statistics or videos so you would say
hey i want to
so how many of you were there and did
you like uh get a little bit of funding
out of stanford like when you decided to
launch this thing yeah well i mean i was
22 i think when we started the company
and i actually was living in argentina
learning to dance tango and on the
evenings
working on this startup from my from a
cafe
um but i yeah i mean we we had a few
stanford friends of mine
and senior year uh get together we
raised venture capital
um from um actually raised angel
investing uh for angel invest
investing money from a couple fathers
and
friends of some other friends of mine
from stanford
and we got our first deal with the
washington post this is back in the
heyday of people
asking what would the future of news and
online context be
and the idea was could we do something
really different and radically new when
it came to news online in fact it was
about social impact like for example
could you see the congressional voting
record
of every single politician while you
were reading the new york times and see
the video that they gave
of the speech that they gave on the
house or senate floor
right there in the article without
leaving the page and we actually built
that so
on the washington post for a few years
in 2007 2008
you could click on any congress member
and then see their voting record
and videos of them on the house or
senate floor without even leaving that
article so we were really trying to
create a kind of transparency and
positive social impact and a
reifying of what would make democracy
stronger
of course and this is where the story
turns what what happened was that
publishers like the economist or new
york times or washington post would ask
us okay
we thought we wanted you to help you
know give people these interesting
features to learn about whatever they
want
it ultimately our success metric for
them was did we increase
the amount of time people spent on their
website and that's when it really hit me
that my personal goal which is more of a
social impact almost
aesthetic or art driven goal of can we
make you know democracy stronger or give
people better information
was really a different thing than the
business goal which is about
maximizing engagement and attention even
on news websites
and the fact that i couldn't reconcile
that in my own mind that every day
i would kind of tell one story to our
team of engineers we were only about a
ten person company
um you know we would tell one story to
them of we're trying to make the world
you know more curious and help people
learn about things but then there'd be
this other
side of it which was measuring our
success on how much time we were getting
people to spend
and i tried to pretend for a long time
that was the same thing you know just
like at facebook like we're making the
world more open and connected yes we are
doing that
but we're also maximizing just
engagement and they seem really aligned
right if one is happening like i'm
making the world more open and connected
then the other thing should be happening
people are spending more time
so it's easy to fool yourself into
thinking that they're the same thing
and you know i don't think i've actually
told this this story before but
it was through um a set of other tech
founders and i gathering for something
we call
doubt club that i decided to basically
cave in and just
frankly you know let google acquire the
company for parts
because you know it was hard to admit to
myself
that really we weren't going to go
anywhere and that this was
this was something that we were going to
be trapped in this attention game
forever
and there would be a limit to the kind
of growth that we could get because we
had to fight for every publisher that
that um that used our service on their
website
so we started a group called doubt club
where several founders you know
realizing that when you're a tech
founder
you can't really express you know that
is a very isolating thing being a
founder because you're there
and it's like you're telling your team
hey we we're going around the corner and
to tell the investors
hey we're going around the corner like
there's no one
like there's no founder that's going to
be like hey guys i actually have my
doubts about this because one of the
things that happens
is that any doubt you have gets
amplified and magnified tenfold for
like anyone around you i'll tell you
running for president was like that too
it's like
you know like like if the candidate
starts updating doubts people be like
wait a minute i'm dedicating my career
to like trying to get this person
elected what you know so like you have
to be
freaking stoic and on top of it at all
times
completely right i mean and that's
that's the pressure as you're talking
about i mean
in many leadership roles you know
there's no safe place to sort of say
man i'm not sure if this is really the
right path or
maybe this business model is maybe we
shouldn't exist even you know
can you even think those thoughts or are
those thoughts unaffordable to you so
this group was really profound we we had
several friends and the first rule about
doubt club is don't talk about doubt
club because
definitely don't talk about that yeah i
mean we had to be
many many many of us we knew each
other's investors and so
if you're given a safe space to talk
about maybe this shouldn't exist
um you know you're not going to go off
and you're going to keep that secret
obviously so
it was through that social support
though that several of us ended up
letting our companies become
talent acquired and what i mean by that
really is acquired for for parts i mean
this was not a successful acquisition
and then another person in that group
ended up just shutting down their
organization
and company but again i think what it
really had
us recognize is the internal conflicts
and the kind of denial that we can face
when we're
sitting on top of something you've
raised millions of dollars you've got 12
people working for you've got
livelihoods that depend on you
can you be really honest about when
maybe the thing that got you here
isn't what is really still happening
that that social purpose
and um and that's when you know i think
this started to turn for me and i think
that's what's
at the root of when i look at many
people in the tech industry i don't see
them as evil people i see them as
trapped by a set of incentives that i
think now many of them also
agree are true um and this is just kind
of the place we find ourselves
yeah you experience the incentives
directly on two levels uh with aperture
number one is
uh how does my company grow and get paid
and that's related to how publishers
grow and get paid and that's
time spent on their website so they can
sell more advertising
and then the the second set of
incentives is um
if i'm in a leadership role in this
organization then
uh what are my imperatives what am i
allowed to express and not express
and those two things are playing out at
a gargantuan almost unthinkable scale
at a place like facebook because for
them instead of being like hey i'm going
to get an extra contract from a
publisher it's like i'm going to get
tens of billions of dollars if
we just keep this thing going and then
if you're
a senior executive at facebook you're
like okay i've got the biggest franchise
in the history of the world
um oh some people are telling me maybe i
should examine my practices well let's
see
i have very very powerful incentives
like pulling me this way
and not really that way uh so you lived
it
and i think you understand it more
deeply as a result
well i think that's actually why andrew
i think our our message
um i want to name there's many more
researchers in the community
who've been studying some of these
problems whether it's doug rushkoff or
sophia nobel or others who
focus on different aspects of these
harms and we're really build on
building on the work of those people but
i think the reason that
when when our message came around that
it really resonated with people
inside the tech industry is it spoken in
the vocabulary and language that they
actually operate in which is
do you have a metrics dashboard do you
measure daus daily active users do you
use do you measure maus do you measure
engagement time time spent seven day
actives we know the common metrics and
design decisions and the kind of
vocabulary
that people on the inside use so i think
when we spoke
it was the first time that i think
people on the inside had to come to
terms with the fundamental misalignment
of incentives that
i think people didn't want to look at
and i just want to name that because
you know while i think we've been
successful at that we're building much
on the insights of people who came
before and have been seeking
these areas whether it's sherry turkle
or you know more recently uh gene twenge
and
jonathan height there's there's lots of
great people who are doing the research
and they're also in the film
um but uh i think we've been successful
because we've been speaking a language
that makes it more universally
understood
for the masses and that's why the film
actually is so exciting because i think
having it received in 190 countries and
in 30 languages
you know being number one in india
number one in lebanon recently
breaking records on for documentaries on
netflix i think it's created a
cultural moment a global cultural
awakening
akin to something like inconvenient
truth or a silent spring but for the
toxic business models of
some of the tech companies it's so
important i am so
uh proud of you and whoever
uh busted their tails trying to get that
movie into the world
and netflix for taking it up and
distributing it thank you netflix
so so you have this tough series of
meetings at doubt club and you say look
i think aptr
is not going to uh to stand the test of
time or grow the way i wanted to
um so then to get yourself aqua hired
for parts
by google is that like an easy thing
because you know
you're a hyper talented guy i'm sure
some of your engineers are hyper towel
does it like
pick up the phone do you have video
friends at google we were like hey like
let's get this conversation going how
does that work
yeah it's an interesting um question um
i didn't i had some friends who were at
google but i didn't know any of the
leadership there
um certainly i think we were you know
what it was actually i could tell you
the story
um there was you remember when cora
first launched
yeah yeah and so adam d'angelo who's the
cto of cora
had um started this question and answer
site which everybody now knows is called
cora
and there is the early community of
quora adopters and
one of the first questions that i think
i think it was zuckerberg who asked the
question on quora and it said
who are the most sorry i'm not trying to
toot my own horn here i'm just trying to
please go ahead what happened but um
zuckerberg had posted who's the
what are the most talented companies and
people the in
silicon valley right now that most
people don't appreciate and there's
obviously lots of lift you know
questions and sorry lots of answers to
that post
but the one that people voted up the
most was actually apture um
and and our team and so i think that
post where we were highlighted as a
uniquely talented group of people um led
to some conversations about acquisitions
with google i
came to know sundar pichai who at the
time was
he's obviously now ceo of google but at
the time he was
head of chrome and apps and um you know
we started an acquisition process with
a small competition it was very
challenging i mean actually you know
these things take a long time and it was
uh
really one of the most stressful and
depressing periods of my life to be
honest because
you have to admit that you know you've
been working for six years incredibly
hard and it's all just
you know you're gonna we got eaten up by
the borg i mean our entire service and
all the publishers and all the code and
all the data and everything we had done
got you know you know became became ash
uh once we got acquired but
um i think it did teach me some many
valuable lessons and i think it created
the foundation for the design ethics
work that took us
to now thank you for listening in i hope
you enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to
yangspeaks and click on notifications so
we can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you